you don't mess with a beaucoup louvoyé g
car en plus de voix aujourd'hui marino
fin j'étais encore pire qu'avant je
voulais pas faire une vidéo puis je me
suis dit bon comme faire un petit truc
rigolo je vous ai demandé sur twitter de
me donner des passages de chansons très
court que je vais devoir chanter avec ma
voix cassée on va voir si ça fait
vraiment peur au coeur et sexy le
refrain de rita note aaa
là je suis pas sur un bus qui crée le
iritano elle colore demis yellow assez
mal à quoi c'est pas normal d'avoir mis
ici it annonce sur sa voix à seat en est
simple on fait ça va burn burn burn
burnes purement purhmv urnes et voilà
merci à tous allumés
le cheval lui nettement l'offre et j'ai
mal à la gorge
on va reprendre une petite pastille à
aider moi chandelier way
des chants de la main sur une vidéo où
il ya des fesses de petite fille c'est
glauque wrecking ball et ça va aller je
pense parce qu'elle parle au début
vraiment c'est presque du slam grand
corps cyrus on l'appelle oui claude rich
and then we just ask why attend un truc
là bas will always want you chanté je
vais rien fait du tout c'est ma voix que
je traînerais qu rihanna diamonds avec
ma voix ça ferait un truc très beau ça
oui la diamond and sky wild aux
alouettes
et comme ça je suis pas du tout rythme
dans la peau aujourd'hui quoi à ce que
j'ai pas fait ça lâche anti-retour
diamant dans le ciel à l'ops ayache et
coûteux dans mon bureau quoi se détendre
tout c'est finalement chez tous nos
trios guen de wiz khalifa bin ouais
ouais bécane bordel de merde et à sang
partout ils sont cachés mais qu'est ce
qui nous arrive à le premier penning de
l'attaqué des titans aller on a réussi à
le cas les mêmes dans une vidéo comme ça
après parole est compliqué c'est
débattent et non
mais la mort partout sur mesure au
casque l'a tuée à bout de souffle
là je suis pas bien donc le comprimé tu
va le prendre quatre fois par jour c'est
qu'à rentrer au losc faisait part pourra
lui est plutôt à la gorge de laisser
passer
gb sur des vidéos mais maintenant les
doigts trop dur freestyle le plus pourri
du monde à tout projet avocats ses
énergies sur hier cette vidéo je peux
faire tout témoin ouf
trois enquêtes de pépettes voilà et
c'est la mort qui m'a tassé asséné lucas
deaux venue ce soir où ses abonnés pour
le show était la meilleure chanson du
monde ça ça ça ressort à l'heure
actuelle sa fab à regarder mais ce style
unique bordel au dessus de noël au
dessus du lot
c'est magnifique c'est leur manière
garde à ceux qui assassinent les masses
un formateur en boxe un seul parce que
je connais qui a assassiné
bah tiens c'est ça ce clip est
exceptionnel quoi est cet homme derrière
kitsch d'abord battu contre une canette
génial style adore ça il prend du
plaisir et ça marche il a séduit en
faisant ça tu veux sortir avec moi vidéo
je suis désolée c'était plutôt court
voilà j'espère que ma voix en fait je
vais malin mais en vrai je souffre
voilà qui vous a plu quand meme si
c'etait pas aimé la vidéo si c'est le
cas cela fut plaisant de faire cette
petite vidéo j'avais envie aujourd'hui
quand même d'en faire une
on se retourne la vie dans une prochaine
vidéo mère ça vous regarde et puis je
vous dis que tout le monde est en
chuchotant pis
des mamans
oh
beau